[Music]
this is my house i have to defend it
home alone it's about uh this kid who
beats us senselessly and uh that one
is uh i look up and i pull on a cord and
an iron
comes uh screaming down on my forehead
step on a nail step on a lot of
christmas ornaments
paint can in the face
[Music]
shovel in the face tarantula
it's about a little boy
who accidentally gets left home alone
around christmas time
i made my family disappear
well in the beginning supposed to be
like uh brat that's how he got sent up
to his room
and my parents found out that the alarm
clock didn't go off and they had to
run to the airport we've forgotten
something we run through a list of
things no it's something else and
something else
kevin and there's two robbers in the
neighborhood
robbing all the houses and he's very
smart little seven-year-old
this is it don't get scared now and so
he finds out that we're gonna break into
his house
and he uh he has to defend the homestead
and uh
with all these homemade traps and and we
fall for every
single one of them as you can see this
is just some of it
[Music]
hello
when we try to get into the house and
get him he just devastates us
[Music]
actually this one here i think it's on
this side
uh there's a triangle on my head on one
of the two sides this side
and uh that one is uh i look up and
i pull on a cord and an iron comes uh
screaming down on my forehead so it sort
of leaves this iron imprint
and this side of my face is uh smashing
into a wall
on a rope swing and sliding down it's
like when a wiley coyote hits the wall
and slides down
feet or he leaves a tar
on the stairs and
then i lose my shoes
step on a nail step on a lot of
christmas ornaments paint can in the
face
shovel in the face tarantula the
character that i do it's like he's
cursing
but you'll see it in the film when he
gets when he gets angry i mean he curses
but
he's not cursing the words are cartoon
words it's hysterical
[Music]
what i have five favorite phrases out of
the whole movie
our lunch it's a wrap see you next
monday
see you next week it's been nice working
with you
he's terrific the kid he's this kid is a
wizard
i mean it's it's really strange talking
to him you know
but he knows everything he still turns
around this big friendly smile like we
said
this is me in a two shot this is just a
two shot of me and dan
i mean he knows all the lingo you know
he's he's great he's really smart
you're what the french call les
encompeton
what the kids on this movie are so cool
they're really funny they're they're uh
smart
feels like you're talking to someone
your own age which probably doesn't say
much for me but
it's gonna be great for kids to watch i
like it too and i can't wait to see it
what they would say that they like my
part and it was
a good movie and it seems
like it'll be a nice funny christmas
story which would be great it would be
great to be part of a good christmas
movie
because i always love christmas movies
and i have mine that i want to see every
christmas so it would be neat if this
was one of those
[Music]
you